Простір-час — це не сцена.
Це актор.
Маса та енергія тиснуть на нього; тензор Ейнштейна вимірює, наскільки глибоко вони тиснуть.
Місяць.
Його радіус Шварцшильда — лише 0,11 міліметра, менше за піщинку.
Кривина, яку ви бачите, — це те, що насправді відчув би мураха на поверхні Місяця.
Земля.
r-індекс-s дорівнює 8,95 міліметра.
Уся планета мала б стиснутися до такого розміру, щоб стати чорною дірою.
Ми обертаємось навколо Сонця, ми відчуваємо гравітацію — але геометричне викривлення тут лише одна частка з мільярда.
Сонце.
Радіус Шварцшильда — 2,95 кілометра; фізичний радіус — майже 700 000 кілометрів.
Лійка виглядає глибокою тільки тому, що ми малюємо в одиницях r-s.
Насправді простір-час навколо Сонця досі плоский на 99,9996 відсотка.
Але цього достатньо,
щоб відхилити світло зір на 1,75 кутової секунди — саме це підтвердило загальну теорію відносності 1919 року.
R136a1 — найважча відома одиночна зоря.
Близько 200 мас Сонця, у Тарантулі.
І все одно гравітаційне викривлення на її поверхні — лише 8 × 10⁻⁵.
Зорі не можуть зламати простір-час самою лише масою — тільки колапсом.
Чорна діра 10 мас Сонця.
Тепер R дорівнює r-s.
Уся параболоїда Фламма відкрита.
Усередині горизонту час і радіус міняються ролями.
Ось так виглядає простір-час, продавлений за межу.
Але в неї лише одна горлянка.
Усе, що падає всередину, назовні не повертається.
Зоряна Брама.
Дві геометрії Шварцшильда, склеєні горлом — міст Ейнштейна-Розена.
Дві горлянки, один тунель.
Щоб утримати горло відкритим всупереч його прагненню колапсувати,
потрібна екзотична матерія — матерія з від'ємною щільністю енергії.
Скільки енергії це коштує?
Рівняння Ейнштейна дають класичну оцінку: c⁴ × b₀, поділене на G.
Для брами шириною два метри, достатньої для людини, — це 2,4 × 10⁴⁴ джоулів.
Щоб уявити це число: приблизно 10³¹ Хіросім.
Одиниця з тридцяти однома нулями.
Це дорівнює всій ядерній зброї Землі, підірваній одночасно, шістнадцять септильйонів разів поспіль.
Чотириста секстильйонів років усієї світової енергетики.
Або, найпряміше: півтори маси Юпітера, перетворені на чисту енергію.
Квантові нерівності Форда-Романа дозволяють екзотичній енергії лише ℏc, поділене на b₀.
Для тієї ж брами — менше за мільйонну частку мільярдної частки джоуля.
Класична вимога перевищує квантовий ліміт на сімдесят порядків.
Поки фізика не закриє цю прірву — Зоряна Брама лишається наукової фантастикою.